what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
really really exciting news about
something that i know a lot of people
have been really wanting to know about
lately and that is the midnight suns in
the mcu it looks like there are some
pretty big developments happening with
the midnight suns with the monster verse
that is clearly being established in the
mcu right now and recently we have
discovered that an actress has been cast
to play a specific midnight sun's
character in the mcu that is going to be
introduced in werewolf by night and this
character has connections to moon knight
which we're watching right now of course
doctor strange and wong which is about
to come up in multiverse madness and
characters like ghostwriter it's looking
like the mcu is setting up the midnight
suns and it looks like today we have
gotten one step closer so let's talk
about this new character that is
reportedly coming to the mcu elsa
bloodstone and who could be on the mcu's
version of the midnight suns slash the
supernatural avengers team and if you're
new and you love marvel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos so like i mentioned
today we have a report that says elsa
bloodstone is coming to the mcu and will
be making her debut in werewolf by night
and will be played by laura donnelly now
last january deadline reported that the
never star lord donnelly would be
joining the mcu in werewolf by night
however at the time they said that there
was no official word on the character
that she is going to be playing but they
said that she could potentially be
playing nina price who would become
vampire by night which still would have
been pretty cool but evidently is not
the case today the cosmiccircus.com is
reporting that laura donnelly is going
to be playing elsa bloodstone a monster
hunter in the comics and in the comics
is also a member of one of the midnight
sun's teams and right now it is assumed
that she will not only appear in
werewolf by night but will also continue
to appear in other projects in the mcu
in the future and as we know there are
plenty of supernatural projects coming
up in the mcu in fact at one point in
time it was even rumored that she would
be making an appearance in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness so
let's talk exactly who elsa bloodstone
is her connection to moon knight doctor
strange and what the midnight sun's mcu
team is currently looking like right now
now as far as the supernatural side of
the mcu goes elsa bloodstone fits right
in now quick origin on elsa bloodstone
her father was ulysses bloodstone and he
sucked he was a monster hunter and
wanted her to be the same and literally
since she was just a baby would have her
fighting monsters for her first kill her
dad made her fight a clippeth but she
took 10 seconds too long to kill it and
its blood got all over her head her dad
commanded her that she leave it on there
to let it get infected as a sign of her
inadequacy needless to say her mom
wasn't too happy about this so her dad
decided that he needed to remove the
mother from the equation so he put her
in contact with some monsters had her
declared mentally insane and put her in
a menstrual institution so needless to
say not a good guy however eventually
with old age he would go on to die and
elsa bloodstone decides that she wants
to be a monster hunter now she is
equipped with the bloodstone or the
blood gem the blood gem was a part of a
meteorite that was sent to earth by the
exomined the blood gem grants elsa a
number of powers the normal ones of
course superhuman strength speed
durability reflexes etc but they also
give her psychic powers and esp in the
case of her father however elsa also has
access to some magical books such as the
darkhold and we know that the darkhold
is going to play a very important role
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness she also has access to many
magical artifacts including a
teleportation portal generator so like i
said she fits right into the
supernatural side of the mcu and in the
comics she is a member of the midnight
suns and here's where a lot of mcu
connections come in now some people may
know that there are actually different
versions of the midnight suns in the
comics there are different teams put
together but elsa's team has kind of a
specific connection to upcoming projects
in the mcu right now in the comics
strange gets into a little bit of
trouble so wang decides to help him out
and calls a new midnight sun's team the
new team consisted of blade mr knight
elsa bloodstone dr voodoo man thing iron
fist and ghost writer this is a pretty
exciting team i would love to see this
team in the mcu now one division sort of
kicked off the supernatural side of the
mcu and moon knight is carrying it on
right now and as i mentioned mr knight
who we saw in moon knight episodes 2 and
3 is a part of elsa bloodstone's
midnight sun's team and i'm hoping that
after the end of moon night steven grant
sticks around with mark spector and we
have moon knight and mr knight in the
mcu still now here's kind of the cool
thing about moon knight i know there's
been a lot of talk that moon knight is
almost kind of a one-off thing from
marvel it's not heavily connected to the
mcu although of course it takes place
inside of the mcu we've only really had
a couple of connections to the mcu as a
whole they mentioned mad report and we
have a statue of the black panther god
best but here's kind of the cool thing
about the midnight suns team they're not
really like the avengers they don't kind
of know who each other are kind of have
a little bit of contact with each other
and then come together as a superhero
group to save the day they're all kind
of just brought together to form a quick
team to do a quick job in fact in some
cases some members don't even
necessarily like each other and have
fought before but they come together for
the greater good to save the world and
this kind of works for moon knight
because there isn't too big of an mcu
connection there but there doesn't have
to be doctor strange and wong should be
monitoring everybody now they're going
to have their hands full of multiverse
of madness but their job is to basically
monitor reality protect it and keep tabs
on other super people so i'm sure
they're aware of mr knight and moon
knight and mark specter and steven grant
and anybody else who is hiding in there
jake lockley so as blade gets introduced
into the mcu and other people like
brother voodoo clea werewolf by night
and hopefully ghostwriter pretty soon
doctor strange and or wong can summon
this new team of supernatural avengers
together to fight some supernatural
enemies now there's gonna be a ton of
cameos in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness but hopefully some
of them stick around and aren't just
variants there's been a rumor going
around for a while that brother voodoo
and clea will be introduced in
multiverse of madness and the reports
aren't that their variants are going to
be introduced but their characters as a
whole are going to be introduced and be
sticking around in the mcu and i am
hoping that some type of variants from
the defenders are going to appear as
well luke cage iron fist maybe some
inhumans the midnight suns team
obviously doesn't have to be exactly
like it was from the comics but if you
take a look at some of the characters
that are in the mcu are coming we
actually have a pretty good lineup so
far of course we would hope that doctor
strange would be a part of it blade of
course maybe even deadpool seen as how
elsa bloodstone has ran into deadpool in
the comics and has even worked together
with him at one point in time we also
have kit harington's the black knight
coming i really really hope mr knight
and moon knight will be a part of it
eventually as well and of course we have
werewolf by night and fingers crossed
that we get ghost rider in the mcu at
some point in time very soon a lot of
casting rumors for ghost rider have been
going on for a pretty long time now and
hopefully some of them are true and we
are indeed getting a ghost rider even if
it is just a variant in multiverse of
madness i'd still love to see him in the
mcu so expect this new supernatural
character elsa bloodstone to appear in
marvel's werewolf by night which is
supposed to come out this october as a
halloween special then hopefully marvel
continues to explore this darker side of
the mcu and we get an official midnight
sun's team slash a supernatural avengers
team so let me know how excited you are
about this in the comments down below
and let me know who you would like to
see on the mcu's midnight suns team
leave your comments down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all the
latest mcu news for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof